tiercé record à auteuil plus de 45000
rang dans l'ordre 17 3 ap
sauvons la bretagne après la marée noire
le point sur l'opération antenne 2 fr3
un rhum devant deux cent mille fidèles
le pape paul vi à célébrer pâques malgré
la maladie le catéchisme à changer de
nouvelles méthodes un enseignement
différent reportage de pierre jean
peltier voilà mademoiselle monsieur
bonsoir le liban l'italie la bretagne
l'actualité de ce dimanche tourne donc
autour de ces trois le liban avec les
suites de l'affrontement entre
palestiniens et israéliens il ya une
quinzaine de jours
la bretagne avec les suites et peut-être
l'aggravation si cela est encore
possible de la marée noire remet enfin
parce que nous sommes le dimanche 26
mars et que cette année le dimanche 26
mars
c'est aussi le dimanche de pâques c'est
à dire par cela que nous allons commence
dans les cérémonies qui ont marqué
aujourd'hui la célébration à rome de la
plus importante journée de la liturgie
catholique plus de deux cent mille
fidèles se sont rassemblés ce matin sur
la place saint-pierre pour célébrer en
compagnie du pape paul 6 la messe de
pâques devant leur écran de télévision
dans le monde entier
un demi milliard de téléspectateurs ont
suivi cette cérémonie le pape paul vi en
dépit de sa fatigue à célébrer l'office
et puis comme chaque année il s'est
adressé aux catholiques du monde entier
le franc soleil de rome aura décidément
boudé jusqu'au dernier jour ces fêtes
pascales de 1978 néanmoins la foule
était nombreuse ce matin pour accueillir
paul 6 qui sortait vraiment pour la
première fois depuis le début de sa
maladie on l'a remarqué pas de sermons
pour la messe de pâques un message
pascal très court
paul 6 est encore extrêmement fatigué
on se perd en suppositions sur ce dont
paul ci souffre véritablement les
informations émanant du vatican sont
depuis quelques heures moins précise on
peut évidemment interprété la chose dans
les deux sens ou bien le pape va mieux
ou bien comme il l'a toujours fait il a
énormément pris sur lui pour assumer ces
fonctions depuis maintenant 5 à 6 ans au
wat à deux pas de l'hôtel du pape nomme
habillé de noir avec une petite trousse
à la main c'est le médecin du pape prête
à intervenir si quelques défaillances se
manifestent bien évidemment si jours-ci
cours est de nouveau des rumeurs
paul si ça l'est certainement
démissionner un des prélats les plus
importants de la curie romaine a assuré
qu'on ne serait envisagé une telle
éventualité
il y a dix ans déjà paul 6 répondantes à
son ami jean guitton sur ce point u10
est une phrase qu'il fait encore sienne
aujourd'hui être pape
c'est une paternité on ne démissionne
pas de la paternité
park avait commencé hier soir à 23
heures avec la veillée à saint pierre
une veillée présidée en l'absence du
pape par le cardinal confalonieri
bénédiction du feu célébration d'un
lumière et proclamation du message
pascal christ est ressuscité christ est
vivant at on chantait c'est le centre de
l'acte de foi de millions de chrétiens
du monde entier pour signifier cette vie
qui renaît
selon la tradition l'église a baptisé
durant la nuit pascale
à midi c'était la bénédiction urbi et
orbi c'est à dire la bénédiction
solennelle que le pape donne à sa ville
et au monde pour les grandes occasions
cette année la bénédiction a été attendu
par le monde entier avec une attention
particulière
le pape en affirmant qu'il rassemblait
toutes ses forces physiques pour être
sur la place saint-pierre a souligné que
les chrétiens devaient être d'abord
fermes dans la foi
pas d'allusion aux problèmes du monde
mais un appel à la vérité de
l'engagement chrétien
deuxième point de passage obligé de
l'actualité de ce dimanche la bretagne
il y a dix jours l'amoco cadiz battant
pavillon libérien et transportant plus
de 200 mille tonnes de pétrole s'est
échoué sur les rochers à quelques
centaines de mètres de portsall dans le
finistère par le seul fait de sa
cargaison
ce qui n'aurait pu n'être qu'à un
naufrage sans perte de vie humaine s'est
transformé au fil des jours en véritable
catastrophe si aujourd'hui 500 km de
côtes sont polluer la nappe s'étend de
la pointe saint-mathieu à l'île de
bréhat la zone des abers et est couverte
de pétrole à brignogan à l'île de batz
roscoff et à perros-guirec la pollution
est là aussi total pour l'instant la
baie de saint brieuc est épargné mais
personne ne peut dire si elle sera
longtemps
le vent souffle en bretagne et il
souffre actuellement de l'ouest des
nappes de pétrole pourrait se détacher
de la nappe principal et des côtes et
s'étendre maintenant vers le cotentin
nos reporters sont en bretagne je vous
propose de faire le point avec eux
mais ce pascal pape noir à portsall ce
matin la sortie de l'église
chacun s'en est allé de son côté à quoi
bon parler chacun sait que le drame est
irréversible et qu'il sera là encore
pendant de longs mois
alors parce que demain il faudra
beaucoup de courage on a préféré ici ne
pas s'imposer pour un jour le spectacle
insoutenable de la côte
pour sa part la maison et safari tanner
qui en reste à la maison
mais sa façon de peindre est usé les
bancs la même chose oui toujours la même
chose pareille un monstre vaincu l'amoco
cadiz continue toujours à cracher son
venin écrasé par le vent la région de
portsall et est aujourd'hui déserte et
rares étaient les curieux qui avaient
franchi les barrages de la gendarmerie
actuellement je viens de recevoir les
comptes rendus des 2 comment la
compagnie devrait seulement relais les
axes retenus sens absolu pour dégager et
tous les véhicules de secours peuvent
les emprunter sans aucun problème vers
16 heures cet après midi on s'est encore
remis à pomper litres par l'it mètre par
mètre pour se rassurer autant que pour
combattre le mal car rien ne peut être
entrepris d'importants avant la fin
mardi des grandes marées d'équinoxe
bien sûr les bonnes volontés ne manquent
pas mais les autorités préfèrent encore
attendre avant d'accueillir les
volontaires et seuls ces quelques
lycéens parisiens avaient été autorisés
ce matin à s'approcher de la plage
qu'est ce que tu comptes faire bas aider
au maximum par messi pétrole les oiseaux
a besoin de nous et vous êtes nombreux
choix qu'ont une centaine à peu près une
vingtaine de nouveaux sites de pompage
seront installés la semaine prochaine et
l'armée dépêchera 11 compagnies
supplémentaires une aide sans doute
appréciable mais quand on sait qu'il
faut six heures et au moins une
trentaine d'hommes pour nettoyer 10
mètres du rivage
on ne se sent guère soulagé dit m faites
le calcul
il y à un bretagne plus de 140 km des
côtes polluées
oui 140 km à vol d'oiseau qu'à faire en
tout cas pour limiter les dégâts de
cette marée noire comme disent comme le
disent les bretons je crois relever les
manches et se mettre maintenant au
travail mais les bretons n'y suffiront
pas il faut que la france entière se
mobilise comme elle s'est d'ailleurs
mobilisé en d'autres temps et pour
d'autres catastrophes alors en pleine 2
face à ce qui se passe actuellement en
bretagne s'est mobilisée l'oci est avec
vous tous nous allons faire le maximum
comment de paimpol daniel bilalian nous
l'expliquent au soir du troisième jour
dans notre grande campagne de solidarité
antennes de sauver la bretagne nous
lançons officiellement l'opération de
nettoyage des côtes du finistère et les
côtes du nord cette opération est lancée
dans toute la france avec le concours
des stations régionales de fr3 elle a
pour but bien précis de permettre le
nettoyage systématique et rationnelle
des plages et des sites touristiques des
deux départements
et cela dans les semaines qui vont vous
depuis le début de notre campagne
vous l'avez sans doute remarqué nous
avons toujours demandé des choses bien
précises ce soir encore
je vous demande donc de mme écouté
attentivement vous qui dans toute la
france écoutez cet appel et qui vous
sentez volontaires pour cette mission de
solidarité groupe et vous en équipe
d'une trentaine de personnes en moyenne
disposant d'un encadrement sérieux
l'âge minimum pour faire partie de ses
équipes afin qu'elle soit véritablement
efficace et de 17 ans les équipes ainsi
constitué doivent être prêtes à
séjourner une semaine au moins sur les
lieux de nettoyage c'est important le
problème
de leur équipement individuel sera
résolu en partie en grande partie sur
place pour l'instant les responsables
départementaux de la jeunesse et des
sports des deux départements sont en
train de recenser les demandes des
municipalités et les possibilités
d'hébergement
dès que vous serez groupe et vous
pourrez donc les appeler mais attention
pas avant d'être sérieusement regrouper
j'insiste bien car les appels
individuels
même s'ils partent d'un bon sentiment ne
font que compliquer les choses et les
rendre pratiquement inefficace voici les
téléphones ou pourrait appeler je vous
conseille plutôt à partir de demain
matin pour les conduit nord à saint
brieuc 3 numéro 33 13 88 33 28 43 et 33
24 15 pour le finistère un seul numéro
pour l'instant mais il y aura sans doute
beaucoup plus dans l'avenir 44 29 24 44
29 24 aux opérateurs qui vous répondront
vous donnerez l'adresse et le téléphone
du responsable du groupe de façon à ce
qu'on puisse vous joindre le plus
rapidement possible dès que les
opérations de nettoyage commence
n'hésitez pas à appeler je vous
conseille car les besoins sont immenses
pour le seul département du causse des
côtes du nord par exemple les
possibilités d'hébergement sont déjà de
3000 places environ
vous pouvez également toujours dans le
cadre de cette opération pour la région
parisienne seulement appelé dès demain
matin
le 555 32,82 555 32,82 magazine c'est la
vie antenne de paris qui regroupera les
appels des volontaires de la région
parisienne
et puis à partir de mardi matin vous
pourrez appeler l'ensemble des stations
régionales de fr3 où seront également
regroupées les offres de service des
volontés enfin si tout va bien et il
faut que tout aille bien
dès mercredi soir 20h30 nous serons en
direct dans notre magazine questions
temps capable de donner un premier bilan
de cette nouvelle opération antenne 2
r3 avec le soutien et le concours des
responsables régionaux
voilà donc pour cette opération et je
voudrais profiter de la présence ce soir
à mes côtés monsieur le sous-préfet de
guingamp pour lui demander si ils
pensent qu antenne 2 dans cette
opération a choisi est la bonne solution
pour travailler
oui et pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que dès le premier soir
vous avez appelé chaque touriste être
présent en bretagne cet été et les
bretons sont sûrement très sensible à ce
qu'on leur apporte ce soutien de la
présence non pas simplement aujourd'hui
où il ya quelque chose à voir
et comme les admire ce matin ce n'est
pas la fête mais plus tard quand il
s'agira de faire revivre cette région
d'autre part parce que votre démarche
par des besoins effectifs en liaison
avec ceux qui ont effectivement la
charge d'organiser les secours et c'est
très important
les camions les hébergements les groupes
et c'est là effectivement que dans le
concret et on pourra faire face à des
besoins qui surviennent aussi qu'ils
sont très évolutif dans le temps et qui
dureront un certain temps enfin parce
que je crois que vous permettez
effectivement aux français qu'ils ont
montré par la passion qu'ils mettent
dans façon dont ils suivent ce drame de
faire face à ce désir de participation
qui est pour nous quelque chose de très
touchant mais également qui doit être
organisé vous avez raison d'insister sûr
ce point bien merci je voudrais juste
avant de terminer et avant de rendre
l'antenne rappeler que notre opération
camions de vidange se poursuit je tiens
à dire tout de suite que tous les
camionneurs et entreprises qui se
présenteront seront payés c'est
important la seule chose qui ne soit pas
encore exactement déterminer c'est le
montant des barèmes qui seront appliqués
pour vous faire connaître vous continuez
donc appelé car on a besoin de camions
vidange énormément de camions au moins
encore une cinquantaine vous appelez à
saint brieuc le 61 19 50 61 19 50 et à
brest le 90 02 80 ou encore le 90 23 83
voilà pour ce soir d'autres opérations
sont en cours d'élaboration notamment
pour venir au secours des oiseaux en
péril nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler mais pour
l'instant notre prochain rendez vous est
à 23 heures vers 23h dans le dernier
journal hier daniel bilalian nous a
donné tous les renseignements mais si
vous voulez participer à ces opérations
nettoyage sur la côte bretonne je vous
rappelle deux choses
deux points essentiels il faut que vous
ayez plus de 17 ans et que vous vous
regrouper en équipe d'une trentaine et
il faut aussi que vous preniez contact
donc soit avec les stations régionales
de fr3 dès mardi matin soit avec nous
que si vous habitez bien sûr la région
parisienne en appelant nos camarades de
c'est la vie dès demain matin je vous
rappelle le numéro que vous nous
communiquez daniel bilalian un instant
le 555 32 82 et je peux vous dire tout
de suite qu'il y à un second numéro qui
vient d'être mis en service et qui sera
en service dès demain matin à 9h le 555
32 94
cette opération de solidarité vous le
comprenez doit être organisé alors avec
fr3 nous allons nous en charge tout
faire pour lutter contre la marée noire
bien sûr mais il faut aussi tout faire
pour éviter qu'une telle catastrophe ne
se reproduise à l'avenir
dans ce domaine le gouvernement a pris
mercredi une série de décisions pour
réglementer la navigation des pétroliers
au large des côtes françaises trois
textes ont été publiés ce matin au
journal officiel
des textes qui fixent donc les nouvelles
normes de circulation applicable dans
les eaux territoriales et dans les eaux
sous souveraineté nationale désormais à
l'intérieur des eaux territoriales
françaises
les pétroliers n'ont plus le droit de
naviguer à moins de sept milles marins
des côtes c'est à dire à peu près 12 km
entre 7000 et 50 milles marins tous les
pétroliers en difficulté devront
signaler immédiatement les difficultés
auxquelles ils sont confrontés signaler
aux autorités françaises le capitaine
d'un remorqueur ou de toutes autres
bateaux se portant au secours d'un
navire en difficulté à moins de 50
milles des côtes doit lui aussi dès
réception de la demande d'assistance
signalé aux autorités la position et la
nature des avaries du navire en
difficulté
il devra également tenir informés ces
mêmes autorités du déroulement des
opérations de sauvetage des normes
sévères donc
reste à savoir si les bâtiments battant
pavillon de complaisance les
appliquerons à l'avenir l'enlèvement du
baron empain rien de neuf depuis
l'arrestation vendredi soir de l'un des
ravisseurs de l'industriel franco-belge
l'interrogatoire d'alaric cayol n'a
semble-t-il pas fait progresser dans la
quête
celui ci a été inculpé hier et sa garde
à vue se termine ce soir
je viens de l'apprendre le gangster
alain cayol à l'intention de demander
aux ravisseurs de libérer le baron
empain il s'explique selon les
enquêteurs c'est ce qu'il a déclaré en
substance il a été contacté chez lui à
montpellier pour participer à la
récupération de la rançon il devait
toucher 500 mille francs pour cette
démission et alain gagnol poursuit je
comprends maintenant qu'il n'ya aucune
illusion à se faire et que les
ravisseurs ne parviendront jamais à
toucher l'argent
la police dit il n'abandonnera jamais la
piste c'est pourquoi j'envisage de
demander à mon avocat de faire appel aux
ravisseurs pour libérer le plus tôt
possible
le baron empain en tout cas après
l'échec de la remise de la rançon et
l'arrestation de l'un de leur complique
les gangsters ont semble-t-il gardé tout
leur sang-froid en cinq ans maintenant
une longue période de silence un bon
peut-être la reprise des tractations
entre la famille du baron empain et les
gangsters en italie ryan neuf non plus
huit jours après l'enlèvement de
monsieur aldo moro les brigades rouges
italiennes ont cependant fait parvenir
quelques messages aux journaux de
message qui annonce que le procès de
monsieur aldo moro a commencé devant la
justice du peuple
un tribunal du peuple dans lequel le
peuple ne se reconnaît pas on fait
remarquer aujourd'hui les centrales
syndicales ouvrières italie au japon
comme partout ailleurs le mélange
manifestants forces de l'ordre est ce
que l'on appelle un mélange détonnant
mais au japon le camp l'explosion
produit le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que cela s'entend et que cela se
voit hier soir vingt mille manifestants
se sont retrouvés face à quatorze mille
policiers à une soixantaine de
kilomètres de tokyo très exactement
devant le nouvel aéroport de la capitale
japonaise à un aéroport qui aurait dû
être inaugurée normalement jeudi
prochain mais cela semble difficile
maintenant non seulement toutes les
vitres sont bons a changé les peintures
à refaire mais les quatorze mille
policiers n'ont pas réussi à empêcher la
mise à sac de la tour de contrôle il est
vrai qu'il pensait peut-être plus à se
protéger eux mêmes qui à protéger les
installations
vous allez pouvoir le constater
l'écologie au japon ne se confond pas
tellement avec la non violence
les manifestants des paysans expropriés
par l'aéroport mais surtout dégauchis
pendant plusieurs heures
ils ont harcelé les policiers selon une
tactique qui a fait ses preuves
attirer les charges le plus loin
possible de la tour de contrôle la tour
qui était l'objectif de ces manifestants
six d'entre eux réussissent à y pénétrer
en brisant les vitres à coups de masse
pendant que les techniciens de la tour
se sont réfugiés sur le toit
sept hélicoptères envoyés par les
policiers pour secourir les techniciens
et cela dans le plus pur des style
hollywoodien
les policiers qui un peu plus tard
devront employer la même technique que
les manifestants pour pénétrer dans la
salle de contrôle
finalement force est restée à la loire
l'aéroport est inutilisable et le bilan
cent huit arrestations 20 blessés dont
17 policiers ce matin à rome le pape
paul vi a utilisé onze langues
différentes pour souhaiter de bonnes et
joyeuses pâques au monde parmi ces
langues il y avait la raab un appel à la
paix qui risque hélas de ne pas être
entendus dans cette poudrière qui
s'appelle actuellement le liban certes
les casques bleus s'installe
progressivement en tampon entre les
israéliens et les palestiniens dans le
sud du pays mais à l'intérieur du liban
le fossé qui sépare les communautés
chrétienne et musulmane et progressistes
et loi d'être comblé et au contraire
cette semaine les chrétiens du liban
célébrer les fêtes de la semaine sainte
mais sitôt les cérémonie terminée il
semble bien que la loi de l'évangile
doivent laisser la place à la loi des
armes
notre reporter bernard rappaz vécu cette
semaine dans la communauté chrétienne du
liban dimanche des rameaux au sud liban
le même jour 80 km plus au nord à
antélias dans la banlieue de beyrouth
ici tout le monde et chrétiens ce qui
signifie pour les libanais conservateurs
et même au plus fort de la guerre civile
aucun commando des forces progressistes
ne s'est aventuré jusqu'ici
pourtant aujourd'hui les événements qui
se déroulent au sud
l'intervention israélienne sont au coeur
de toutes les conversations avec parfois
des nuances difficile à séville qui se
révoltent parce qu'elle va gagner parce
que le chien allait un peu mieux que les
palestiniens parce que les deux côtés
les deux côtés vont nous tuer mais mais
c'est un peu mieux que les palestiniens
les wafers le palestinien a été chez
nous comme ça ils ont déjà une excuse
pour venir combattre libre pour les
chrétiens ennemi principal ce sont les
palestiniens du souvenir de la guerre
civile est encore très présent dans les
coeurs toute solution qui laisserait la
moindre chance de retour au sud liban
pour les palestiniens est inacceptable
et l'envoi de casques bleus est
considéré par les leaders chrétiens
comme une mauvaise farce
on ne croit pas ici que les troupes de
l'onu parviendront jamais contrôler les
fedayin et à tout prendre on préfère
encore voir les israéliens au sud-liban
plutôt que les palestiniens pour
l'expliquer le président du parti
national libanais camille chamoun n'y va
pas par quatre chemins
certains pays considèrent qu'une attaque
contre leurs rivaux qui est menée par
l'israélien constitue une agression une
violation de la souveraineté libanaise
alors qu'une attaque palestinienne
toutes les destructions
comment on va lui les attaques
palestiniennes
ceci ne constitue pas une atteinte à la
souveraineté du liban et sur toutes les
troupes venues son territoire ce qui
fait que maintenant nous considérons et
personnellement je considère que ce qui
était la résolution du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies est une
résolution boiteuse c'est la mise en
place des casques bleus ne vous
satisfait pas quelle est la bonne
solution pour vous alors une solution
pour nous y compris une solution que les
casques bleus s'ils veulent vraiment
travailler bien qu'ils essaient par
désormais également les palestiniens que
je souhaitais vous maintenant maintenant
qu'ils savent comment diable vert
pour l'instant les palestiniens sont
toujours ou l'iman l'opération
israélienne et pour résultat que de les
repousser à 20 km au nord entraînant un
mouvement de population considérable qui
pourrait bien faire une nouvelle fois
explosé la chaudière libanaise et la
prière ni pourrait rien
voilà pour ce tour d'horizon de
l'actualité mondiale
80% des français s'affirment de religion
catholique même si beaucoup d'entre eux
ne pratiquent plus assidûment ce chiffre
c'est un récent sondage qui nous le
faisait connaître 80% de français élevé
dans la religion catholique
cela veut dire finalement 80% de
français ayant connu l'époque du
catéchisme jusqu'à la modification du
jour de congé hebdomadaire on y aller le
jeudi
maintenant les couvre bien qu'ils ont
lieu le mercredi mais le catéchisme de
nos pères est il le même que celui de
nos enfants
la réponse j'oublie tout de suite et non
et si l'église en 2000 en a beaucoup
évolué du côté du catéchisme ceux des
révolutions dont on doit parler
nous avons vécu d'un jeune député
sous le regard d'un personnage féminin
les belles images du catéchisme nous
montrer dieu comme une sorte de grand
père terrifiant et barbu émergent des
nues est assis sur sa création il tirait
les ficelles d'une histoire qui remonte
est beaucoup plus haut que nos ancêtres
les gaulois jusqu'au paradis terrestre
toutes les ressources de la pastorale
écologique et est ici mise en loge et la
nudité de nos premiers parents étaient
pleines de ces options
le serpent et sa pomme gâtée trop vite
notre plaisir
regardez avec combien d'éloquence et
encore évoqué aujourd'hui la tentation
pour combattre le péché les petits
livres d'hier ne lésinez pas sur les
moyens
quant à l' enfer auquel il ne manquait
pas un diable pas un supplice nous le
considérions naturellement comme le
grand dépotoir des mauvais élèves
très concrètement la hiérarchie
religieuse du ciel de l'enfer et du
purgatoire
si familière qu'elle inspirait le jeu de
marelle des petites filles nous initier
à la notion de classe pour faire
comprendre que le dimanche le jour
réservé aux seigneurs le catéchisme de
la bonne presse
n'hésitez pas à attribuer à l' usine
toutes les apparences d'un lieu
infernale mais ce qui nous plaisait le
plus c'était sans doute ces magnifiques
panoramas hollywoodien de déluge de
bataille de miracle tient à notre âge
avait encore la saveur de l'épopée et
des contes de fées
enfin le petit catéchisme illustré
répondait à sa manière à nos premières
curiosité métaphysique au problème de la
mort qu'il représentait dans toute sa
cruauté aujourd'hui on en arrive à une
explication de l'univers très très
différentes à travers toute la poussée
scientifique la poussée industriels la
poussée rationnelle et que le catéchisme
petit à petit s'est trouvée complètement
en porte à faux par rapport à ce type
d'explications de l'univers d'où
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec un
catéchisme qui n'a pu tellement
d'imagerie qui ne veut plus s'adresser
au merveilleux de l'enfant mais qui veut
s'adresser à sa vie et à sa vie concrète
précise de tous les jours et qui veut
essayer de lui faire percevoir comment
dieu se trouve dans cette vie de tous
les jours
effectivement tout a changé
d'abord le cours de catéchisme et
aujourd'hui la sphère des laïcs
la mère de famille remplacer monsieur le
curé chaque semaine 150 mille bénévoles
font ainsi la leçon sous le contrôle de
quelques claire l'enseignement lui aussi
a changé se mettant à l'heure des
nouvelles méthodes de pédagogie l'église
a abandonné le petit livre que nous
avons connue avec sa longue litanie de
questions et de réponses
les chants les danses les saynètes les
discussions les séances de peinture on
remplaçait la récitation parker c'est
qu'aujourd'hui l'objectif n'est plus
d'apprendre mais de chercher à
comprendre
il m'a pardonné avantages que vous
penchez je croyais mourir croyez mourir
je croyais être condamné gym a pardonné
il n'est pas comme les autres
quelle belle surprise et maintenant
malades maintenant je suis heureuse
tout est changé personne ne veut plus me
parler
peux tu m'aider à changer jésus à être
meilleur
l'acd invite aujourd'hui nébulosité
pendant tout un temps on a cru pouvoir
en serre et la fois dans des formules
dans des paroles on avait tout un bagage
la fois c'était un dépôt et il suffisait
de connaître ce dépôt est de savoir ce
dépôt pour pouvoir se dire croyants
chrétiens aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
la fois ce ne sont pas des paroles mais
c'est une personne qui s'appelle
jésus-christ et que donc notre problème
n'est pas de savoir un certain nombre de
choses mais plus de rentrer dans le
mystère de cette personne qui s'appelle
jésus ce qui est beaucoup plus difficile
on était beaucoup plus en sécurité
il y avait là une notion de la vérité en
fin de compte qui était très simple et
très clair on savait ça allait
aujourd'hui on ne sait plus aux
recherches même si nous n'en avons pas
conscience les images des anciens
catéchisme nous ont laissé leurs
empreintes bon gré mal gré elles font
partie de notre imaginaire
aujourd'hui elles ont disparu événement
sans importance ou révolution culturelle
l'église à découvrir que la vieille
imagerie saint sulpicienne autrefois si
efficace et est devenu un obstacle la
fois déboulonné de son nuage
le dieu des catéchismes est descendu
dans la vie quotidienne des petits
français sous la forme d'une initiation
à l'amour la justice et à la générosité
bonhomme le bon dieu se prêtent
désormais à tous les barbouillages il
lui reste tout de même quelque chose de
son ancienne image le collier de barbe
je ne reviendrai pas sur l'actualité
sportive de cette journée robert
chapatte et son équipe vous ont déjà
tout dit dans stade 2 un retour
toutefois sur le tiercé qui se courait
aujourd'hui à auteuil il s'agissait de
la grande course de haies de printemps
les 22 partants avec 4100 mètres à
parcourir je vous le dis tout de suite
les rapports atteigne les sommets le
premier c'est en effet le 17 faire comme
le second le 3r archers et le troisième
l'as demonio le 17 le 3 hélas vous voyez
les rapports s'inscrire sur votre et
quand 45 1717 france 50 pour 5 francs
dans l'ordre et dans un ordre différent
9143 francs 5 ans vos rapports
quant à la course de chameaux commenté
par daniel cazals avec son talent
habituel lors toujours de stade 2 je
suis désolé mais les rapports ne sont
pas encore parvenus ils seront peut-être
là pour leur première année
un rapide coup d'oeil maintenant sur les
prévisions de la météo pour demain il
fera généralement beau sur notre pays le
matin en dépit de quelques brouillards
dans le sud-ouest dans le courant de la
journée le temps deviendra cependant
nuageux de la bretagne à la frontière
belge
des nuages accompagnés d'un renforcement
des vents et de petites pluies dans
l'ouest les températures elles varieront
peu et puis avant de nous quitter un
dernier conseil vous allez peut-être
sûrement même être très nombreux à
rentrer et demain vers les grandes
villes si vous le pouvez alors évitez de
circuler entre 16 heures et 24 heures il
y aura du monde beaucoup de monde sur
les routes à ce monde voilà cette
édition est maintenant terminée à 22h30
c'est hervé claude qui vous tiendra au
courant des derniers développements de
cette actualité du dimanche de pâques
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain soir
à 20 heures bonne soirée à demain